what is going on everybody welcome to
part 13 of our Python with PI QT for the
creation of GUI applications tutorial
video series in this video we're gonna
be talking about the editor and it's
basically a way to add a big ol block a
whiteness that you can put text in kind
of like but we're programming King so
that's what we're gonna be doing here
and then we'll talk about how we could
save it and then actually how we could
open it and all that and Ashley will
probably talk about how we can open it
before we talk about saving it anyway
that's a couple videos down so this
video the editor so what we're going to
go ahead and do with this editor is
we're going to put it up here since this
is where we have other stuff that are in
our kind of file menu what we're gonna
add is an editor so move over here and
we're going to say open editor equals QT
GUI Q action and then kind of like
before where we had this get to the
choppa we're going to have ampersand
editor and then the obligatory self next
up open editor
don't say shortcut and this would make
sense to be ctrl + e next what we're
gonna do is open editor dot set status
tip and that's pretty simple we'll just
do open editor finally open editor dot
triggered dot connect what is the what
do we might want to run here and we're
gonna run self dot editor so that's
basically that now what we're gonna want
to do is go below file menu definitions
here and let's go ahead and do so the
main menu we have here so what we can do
is we can do
editor menu and let me just put this on
a different line there we go editor menu
that's going to equal main menu dot add
a menu and this will be ampersand editor
then we're gonna go edit or menu dot add
action and that will be open editor
awesome so now that we've done that what
we have to add is this editor method
that we're calling so we're gonna come
let's just fix this so we have a bunch
of lines come on down this is the home
method then we come all the way down
sorry if that you heard that vibrate
come all the way down and basically
underneath color picker will add our
editor functionality so what we'll do is
define editor we're going to pass the
you know obligatory self and then we're
gonna say self dot text edit equals
cutie GUI dot Q text edit empty
parameters and then self dot set central
widget and then self dot text edit and
so what this is going to do is it's
going to allow us to basically take up
the entire application so let's go ahead
and save and run that and see how that
works okay so we've got editor we can
click on that and then we can click
editor and then you can see how it
basically took over everything and so
now we can start typing stuff in it it's
like it's it's an editor so that's
pretty cool but to be an editor you
probably need to actually I don't know
edit something so that means we have to
be able to open something to edit it and
then after that we have to be able to
like you know save it for that edit to
be complete so that's what we're going
to be talking about in the coming videos
but that's it for this video
if you guys have any questions or
comments up to this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support of subscriptions and
until next time